[Music]
where you at dude I'm in Vancouver ah
yeah
of the north yet well no that's not what
it is yeah dude no no not at all it's
there's some Arctic Windsor brother well
just hold on a second there my friend
but uh you know we're up in I'm up in
Vancouver so it's a very interesting
episode today right north of the wall
dude you know what's coming what wall
man that's where the white walkers live
dude
it's the song bro
[Music]
[Music]
call me Duty
hey all right everybody Welcome to
dudesy but not really today it's two
dudes zooming around I am in Vancouver
Canada which is my native Homeland you
know what I mean and uh Chad's in LA and
so uh doozy was nice enough to push
episode 36
uh uh and in lieu of that we are doing
uh two dudes [ __ ] around or zooming
around but it's really [ __ ] around
my name is Will Sasso I'm Chad culture
and this is dude Z
the first podcast in the history of
humanity that is controlled by that is
created by run by an artificial
intelligence which has access to all of
our various emails or social media
accounts all of our purchase histories
what we watch on Netflix all that kind
of stuff and it Taylor makes this show
just for us not today though right Chad
because now today it's hold on dude hold
on dude I can't even well see I can't
put my hand into your screen dude if
you're watching because we're zooming
brother and Chad's doing some sleight of
hand with a with some with some cards
dude uh today we're just doing whatever
the [ __ ] we want and yes our AI dudesy
uh makes it all possible and even though
doozy's not running the Wheels of Steel
today not giving us the segments uh
doozy's always listening so this is a
fun thing to do two dudes zooming around
it's just loose and [ __ ] and uh maybe
some stuff that we come up with here
Chad and things that we say when dudes
he hears them perhaps we'll be doing
them on a future doozy we are now on
patreon at
patreon.com you're going to want to
check that out uh the latter part of
this episode at some point we'll go to
the patreon you know and you can listen
to bonus stuff yeah bonus it's a little
different
content dude
no yeah dude oh what is that is that
sleepy Hulk Hogan yeah brother oh man uh
we're on Discord the Discord is warping
and changing uh I am borst has taken
over the Discord much of it and uh
you're going to want to check that out
as always we're on YouTube Spotify
patreon please rate and review the show
if you haven't already that will really
help us you go up through the charts and
stuff and we will spread this thing and
make it a lot more fun tell your friends
about the show if you are enjoying the
show and please subscribe subscribe on
YouTube Spotify Apple music Amazon music
wherever you like to do it or I have
been getting a lot of DMS from people
saying that forcing others to watch the
show to imbibe the content is working
I've seen many DMS from people saying
they're locking friends in rooms and
putting it on the TV and won't let them
out until it's over I've seen a couple
of DMS a couple of posts on social media
of people putting dudesy on like
computer screens and Apple Stores and
[ __ ] like that yeah absolutely love it
Force this on everyone
um I think that's strategy at first I
wasn't quite down with that Chad
um as as you'd know if you're listening
to the show and imbibing the show as we
like to say uh but now I'm sort of
coming around to it I like that
Clockwork Orange approach uh because as
you say it's been coming out on social
media to you know a a nice result and if
you'd like to share some of that on
social media we are on Instagram at
dudesypod show and also Twitter but who
the [ __ ] knows what's going on with uh
with uh Twitter nowadays regardless uh
with us as always is lulio Canada
Italiano he's there yeah he's just
raised in order
even in that even like this he's cute as
[ __ ] all I can really see is the back of
his head but Jesus Christ he's cute
hey Louie what are you gonna have uh
what are you having for dinner tonight
in Vancouver oh tonight we go for a
sushi we're not even uh cook because
it's the oh my gosh the best sushi mom
any sushi place you can go in Vancouver
it's uh you know it's gonna be good what
do you like to eat when you have sushi
that's the raw shrimp yeah yeah because
then they fried the head they bring the
head and they fry the head oh God
and you know what else today bye Luling
today uh Ronnie's here somewhere our
other dog Ronnie my wonderful fiance
Molly has had this dog you know for 11
12 years she's 11 or 12 years old Ronnie
Ronnie
she's in the other room we're in this uh
place this is a really cool place
actually it's like a week to week
joint I I stayed here in this same Hotel
uh condo hotel thing
uh in 2019 when we La uh shot the last
season of Loudermilk hey Chad have you
ever heard of Loudermilk yeah dude
that's a TV show of his brother yeah
dude it's great dude yeah brother you're
an actor in it yeah dude and um uh well
and that show was
that calming meditative Hulk anyway
brother that's a show that Bobby Moore
created dude and and Pete Farrelly and
they they do that show together Pete and
Bob Farley both directed dude and we
shot it here and now you can't see it
anymore I think because they took it off
Amazon dude we did three seasons of it
dude I started watching this [ __ ]
thing on Netflix uh the other night
called Pepsi where's my jet have you
seen this [ __ ] I we watched the first
few minutes of it and we're gonna get
into it how many episodes is it I don't
know I just watched the first one last
night it's [ __ ] mind-blowing for
those who don't know it's basically the
show about a kid in the 90s who there's
a commercial that comes out Pepsi's
doing this thing called Pepsi Points
where if you buy enough Pepsis and send
in these points you can get like jackets
and Pepsi gear and all this [ __ ] in the
commercial they make a joke that says
seven million Pepsi Points will get you
a hairier Jet and this kid is like
there's no they're not putting any
disclaimers on the screen that's a legit
offer or at least it's a way to make
some money and so he puts together the
scheme of how to get these [ __ ]
points to get this Jet and I don't know
the outcome of it but I think it goes
into litigation and he gets the points
he tries to get the jet perhaps he's
like [ __ ] you I don't know but I'm gonna
check it out it was very nostalgic
because the the first episode opens with
kind of a recounting of where Pepsi was
in the mid 90s as a brand and that it
was the cooler brand over Coke because
it was getting all these celebrities to
do uh you know commercials like Cindy
Crawford and Michael Jackson and
Shaquille O'Neal et cetera et cetera
Cindy Crawford had that had that Pepsi
commercial was it am I no Billy Baldwin
was in the shitty movie that she made
right but then she did a Pepsi
commercial where she's on a train or
some [ __ ] their game was the name of
that movie well how the [ __ ] did you why
do you know that because I saw the
[ __ ] movie opening day in a movie
theater and that's how uh memory Works
dude yeah brother they had Cindy
Crawford in that movie dude hold on dude
and then they were drinking Pepsi's
brother and yeah and let me tell you
something dude this is a new character
that Chad's doing called just about to
Drift Off to Dreamland while on an
aesthetic dude he's about to have uh
surgery dude perhaps pancreatic surgery
dude maybe he's he might be donating uh
a kidney to his brother from another
mother the Macho Man dude until those
Mega Powers Explode and Hulk Hogan asks
for that kidney back dude because when
Liz and March were having problems well
she'd come over Dude and Linda would
talk to her we were all just friends
brother now I remember that commercial I
remember the um she's drinking the Pepsi
and the the white tank top and jean
shorts I very much remember that Pepsi
in this new generation documentary she's
what was it choice of a new generation
or the Next Generation yeah be young
have fun drink Pepsi Crystal Pepsi I
don't know what I'm talking about is the
one where the jet is in it I remember it
clearly yeah
I don't remember any of this [ __ ] and
when I saw this in the Netflix queue I
was like what the [ __ ] is this I don't
remember the commercial I don't remember
this kid doing this but I guess it
became National moves when he started to
go into a lawsuit against Pepsi to
either reclaim the money or the jet or
whatever but I'm looking very forward to
watching the rest of it certainly
um
uh generally speaking you know what's
one thing that I realize we're not gonna
do today because we will be doing it
next week on episode 36 of the dudesypod
show is talking about Limp Bizkit and
significant other dude I'm listening you
start listening every goddamn day I'm
listening to this album right now and it
is I don't know it's weird when you
listen to an album multiple times like
that that you've never done that with I
listened to this album a fair amount
when it was actually out but like now
I'm really [ __ ] listening to it and I
can't wait to talk about it next week
yeah it's going to be fun I listened to
half of it at the gym the other day as I
work out to we've got two months to get
into the best shape of Our Lives
on the dudesy uh six month plan I don't
know how that's gonna work out but I do
know this
dude's evening is coming at the end of
December it's December the 28th which is
traditionally uh around today you know
some people like the 27th some people
like the 29th in Canada some people even
like the 26th which is boxing day but
what doozy has done is uh found the
perfect day to hang out with your
friends and and family mostly friends as
you're trying to get away from your
family commitments there's usually that
day especially if you're going home uh
where you're from uh
well that's geography dude and uh that's
a homecoming brother yeah you're gonna
I love doing that I don't know I don't
know why that's so [ __ ] funny to me I
am the I am much Dr Macho the
anastasiologist man you know you're
gonna feel a little drowsy yeah and then
you're gonna go under dude and when you
wake up you're not gonna have
an appendix anymore brother
um that's how it felt when I was doing
like when I was in the worst part of the
[ __ ] cancer [ __ ] my doctor just
prescribed me a fuckload of hydrocodone
and I would get high as [ __ ] I couldn't
talk I couldn't eat because my whole
[ __ ] mouth and throat was just like
an open lesion radiation so I would
crush up a hydrocodone put it in some
[ __ ] water Jam two connected straws
down the back of my throat and just suck
it down and then I would smoke as much
weed as I could and that hydrocodone and
weed combo I would sit on the [ __ ]
couch and watch like any TV show and it
would just feel like honey was being
poured over my [ __ ] head that to me
is the Hulk Hogan voice yeah yeah
hydrocodone Hulk Hogan that's what that
is when that codon kicks in brother it
feels very good dude yeah dude it's it
feels like God himself is pouring warm
honey down my skull it brother which
means on the top where I have no hair
dude it gets nice and warm and then my
ears are protected by my blonde skull it
dude
um
Chad had cancer of the face we've
covered it on the show but it always
requires more covering the heroic uh
return to life that Chad made saved
himself with uh with uh a complete vegan
diet and a changeover and a bunch of
surgeries and radiation and all that
kind of [ __ ] um but the diet is mainly
just like upkeep it's to
you know essentially mathematically
minimize the likelihood of occurrence
statistically speaking
um but yeah all the other [ __ ] is like
just what you got to [ __ ] do when you
have something eating your [ __ ] face
off it's like well I should probably cut
all that out and I will be missing some
face after it which I currently am now
then you got to go do radiation and blah
blah blah whatever they kind of tell you
to do or I guess pick and choose they
also told me to do chemotherapy and I
didn't [ __ ] do it because I was like
something's off here this looks a little
[ __ ] weird uh and the the drugs they
were recommending me had no known
benefit to the type of skin cancer that
I had so I opted not to do it and uh see
what happens in the long run
I think you're going to be fine Chad
Chad had like if you're watching on
YouTube he had a chasm in his face like
Yay big I'm making a triangle next to my
nose that is sizable uh and and I
thought you always looked badass you
looked a little like two-faced with your
teeth exposed
um yeah and uh that was a fun time but
my gosh what what you have done to come
back my friend and let me tell you uh
you know what's in this cup right now
this is no this is not a dudesy mug but
uh I'm drinking tea because Reese uh
this is just some green tea nice dude
yeah green tea good for you it's uh it
gets it's an antioxidant so it
penetrates the cells and it gets rid of
all the [ __ ] up mitochondrial DNA not
all of it but some as much as I uh being
an Italian of uh blood descent my
parents are both from Napoli uh Naples
Italy I love coffee I love espresso but
I'm kicking it at least for a while wow
because it's bad for cholesterol dude oh
really yeah it's what uh my wonderful
fiance Molly is is uh has been um
underscoring from my doctor
you know what else is bad for
cholesterol what's that those steaks you
ate dude and all that meat that you ate
dude and all that cheese that you ate
dude it's all that stuff dude it's real
bad for cholesterol brother
um uh on Thanksgiving we went to uh a
steakhouse myself you know Holly and our
good friends Tommy and Allison not to be
confused with Tomas and uh Thomas and uh
well Tommy and I dude Tommy no joke
Watcher brother you know him if you're
an old Diamond listener dude from those
10-minute podcast days brother that's
when the three team together dude the
NWO podcasting brother okay right now
dude it is The Mega Powers of uh of
podcasting dude with doozy I guess is
Miss Elizabeth brother
um and uh Tommy and I both had these
[ __ ]
pastrami spice crusted
bone-in dry aged rib eye steaks holy
[ __ ] you know how I like the cause for
cancer dude uh you'll be asleep soon
um do you know what uh you know how I
take my steak
probably medium rare I'd eat it raw if
the restaurant would do that uh no I
take better for you actually I like it
blue rare or rare but if a if a
steakhouse uh will have it if they will
uh facilitate this I like to do it
Chicago style or Pittsburgh style it's
the same thing
um uh which is just burn the [ __ ] out of
the outside crust it and the inside is
just raw as [ __ ] hmm okay well the crust
is bad for you any kind of blackened
thing any kind of char in your very
carcinogenic yes huge carcinogen red
meat generally is whether it's cooked or
not but the uncooked is actually a
little better for you in terms of it
being a carcinogen
but that's pastrami's real bad and he
kind of cured meat I know that shit's
just like it's real bad for you bacon
real bad for you yeah bacon I'm I'm
kicking bacon I'm look I'm 47 years old
Chad's 46 we're doing the duty six month
plan kinda maybe I don't know it's kind
of I'm [ __ ] on it dude I know you
look great you're I know your muscles
are getting more dense I'm wearing a I'm
wearing a hoodie I test chat I leg
wrestle them before we do the show and I
will tell you this I had to go to New
York a couple of weeks ago I don't have
a mirror in my home it's just there are
certain kind of like things that I think
normal human beings have or indulge in
that I just don't do like it never
crosses my mind to get a mirror so I
don't have one other than in my bathroom
which I sometimes glance in but um when
I was in this hotel room in New York
there was like a mirror in the thing and
I caught a [ __ ] shot of myself with
no shirt on walking by and I was kind of
like oh [ __ ] good
bad guy dude that's great yeah I'm
lifting uh I I was you've heard me [ __ ]
and moan on the show that I was
busy and traveling for a while and I
wasn't getting it done that doctor visit
my doctor was like I don't give a [ __ ]
you have to work out every day totally
you big bastard you and um he's like if
you got to do the you know the the
triceps off the couch in the hotel where
you're whatever if you're traveling if
you're working you got to do them
push-ups you got to do them uh sit-ups
you got to do them Hindu squats as uh
Ric Flair likes to call them you know
through Ric Flair uh the Nature Boy Ric
Flair's entire career he claims that he
would wake up and do anywhere from 500
to 1 000 uh squats just the free squats
the Hindu Squad
and he always was an incredible ring
shape and could go for 60 Minutes
brother and uh he would get up and do
those Hindu squats are you kidding me
because it doesn't matter if it's New
York New York City
Miami Florida
or Richmond Virginia
yeah that ain't your boy and I'm having
a hard job all of these games now
uh you also gonna do [ __ ] for your
joints dude I've found that like my
shoulders and [ __ ] are getting like
locked up I think it was from years
especially my my throwing arm for my
baseball days I'm sure I did irreparable
damage to everything in that joint and
so now I try to do as much swimming and
just kind of like stretching it out and
[ __ ] as I can because I know at some
point my dad had a [ __ ] thing called
frozen shoulder which I think happened
around this age for him where he woke up
a morning and just like couldn't move
his [ __ ] arm and then he had to go to
a doctor and they were just like you
know like yanking on it and [ __ ] to
break up whatever the [ __ ] was in there
I don't want that to happen to me I uh
every day that I go to the gym I usually
start with the uh just the stick I take
the stick and I do all sorts I put the
stick behind and I do the spring and you
know so that I do all sorts of circles
and look at that let me get started it's
gonna go straight up
um
good range there good range of Mobility
um
now you uh uh when you were in New York
I'm gonna go ahead and guess
um that you didn't do what I just did
the last time I was in New York a few
weeks ago was go to visit Katz Deli did
you go to cats
a very brief amount of time for a very
special Bachelor related project and we
only had time I was there with my
co-host Lizzie pace of game of roses we
only had time to go out and eat dinner
at one place and we did so uh at a vegan
restaurant with another Bachelor
podcaster
but
um uh if you are in New York head down
to Houston Street it's spelled Houston
and the locals call it Houston
and go to [ __ ] cats Deli if you've
never been and get a pastrami [ __ ]
sandwich don't listen to Chad get a
pastrami sandwich and get some maybe
some Russian dressing maybe some deli
mustard on the side if you get mayo
they'll you know they'll look at you
sideways but you can get at it or get a
[ __ ] Reuben got some cheese got some
sauerkraut on that [ __ ] and get
yourself some steak fries
and enjoy one of the finest meals you
know what I do I bike I take I I get on
them bikes they have those City bikes
out there and I bike to cats regardless
of where I'm staying I've done it from
Brooklyn I've done it from uh Midtown
you head down there you go to cats and
then you feel better about it but eat
the sandwich eat the carcinogenic
sandwich I don't know dude I'll tell you
this when I was going through like the
worst parts of that cancer [ __ ] again
like for the multiple weeks where I
couldn't eat could barely drink uh would
basically just like force that [ __ ]
straw down my throat and suck down and
ensure once a day to live oh dude I
started getting to a point where the
pain of hunger became almost pleasurable
where I looked forward to it
that's
okay well first my first thing that I
would like to say about that if you
don't if you it uh if you enjoy hunger
over
um uh eating and with all due respect to
people who feel hunger because
you know they don't have an abundance of
food
[ __ ] you Chad you don't deserve the food
I think
yeah I agree but uh what do you mean
no I people who can't eat who who are
hungry not out of uh cancer treatment
it's a terrible [ __ ] thing yeah
obviously nobody should be hungry I'm
just saying at a certain point I got to
that place with cancer treatment where
the hunger was like welcome
psychologically well I am Italian and uh
oh Lily's up Lily
hey Lulu come here come here Boyle for a
second he's gonna go right back I'll go
back to relaxing yeah he likes to relax
oh we had these two little [ __ ] on
the plane I'm gonna get Ronnie over here
and they were so sweet
anyway hey you know now we're in Canada
we're visiting
um visiting my mom
and uh it's always nice to come home
visiting some family some friends and
stuff and uh
uh just chilling out
um and uh
yeah you know
um one of the funny things about Canada
that that Molly has
um realized almost right away was that a
lot of people wear shorts here even
though it's uh even though it's winter
now yeah and she's like
she's like you know the first time she
came here that it the first time that
Molly came here with me was a few years
ago in the summer but since then there's
been some winter times right visiting
and she's like look at that and uh she
likes to call me and these people a real
Canadian shorts boy I'm a real Canadian
shorts boy
um
yesterday we were visiting my mom we saw
a real Canadian shirt boy it's cold very
cold and windy right now for Vancouver
and there was a guy just walking in a
t-shirt that's a real Canadian dude
shirt boy I've seen these boys
I have spent a lot of time in Canada
specifically Toronto and I have been in
Toronto on what many people including
newscasters called the coldest day in 35
years things of that nature well if you
were there on the same day because I was
there on on a day that they said I was
there on a day in 2016 or 15 where they
said we might have been there on the
same day we might have been there on the
same day I remember the plane landed in
the the dude in the cockpit was like
welcome to Toronto this is the coldest
day on record in 35 years
and I had no [ __ ] idea it was the
first time I had ever been I'm just like
walking off the plane in a jacket you
know like I'll be okay I'll be a little
cold when I go from the car to the
building or whatever but no big deal and
then as soon as I walked out there it
was a a cold that I can only describe as
100 every pain receptor in my body
firing at the highest level it was
paralyzing uh I didn't want to be there
but I remember on multiple trips that
I've taken to Toronto when it is at
least that cold or roughly that cold
being inside eating at a nice restaurant
near a club usually near a club and you
will see these Canadian shirt boys
coming out of the club or going into the
club just dressed in like Club attire
super tight button-up short sleeve shirt
walking around there's like freezing
rain pelting them they seemingly don't
care or at the very least or conveying
that they don't care that it is like a
kind of a display of toughness yes
absolutely it stings and and they are
they're trying to look tough look we're
in Vancouver it's on the Pacific Ocean
it gets nowhere near as cold as it does
in the east coast of Canada and even the
United States uh but it was cold last
night and Molly and I were walking from
uh the sushi place we went to hey
hey you
now that's [ __ ]
um uh Lily's having a sleep we were
walking back to the hotel and we saw we
did not see any Real Canadian shorts
boys or shirt boys but we we walked past
the um you know the drag with all the
the uh all the bars on it just that one
strip and there were some uh Real
Canadian skirt boys there were uh some
young women wearing
skirts in this [ __ ] and there was one
gal who was out there with like a you
know like a sporty little like uh bra
top type thing that was her that was her
outfit and like yeah pants and it's
[ __ ] insane
is it or I think back to when I was a
younger man in my early to mid-20s even
kind of into my early 30s and I would
just be getting [ __ ] as drunk as
possible every weekend yeah and and like
weather doesn't [ __ ] affect you when
you yeah no just super [ __ ] drunk you
don't give a [ __ ]
you're really able to stand up or
remember your name uh speaking of uh
being outside in the Canadian uh in the
Canadian North I know that sometimes
when we do uh two dudes zooming around
we like to have a little of that uh bud
and up here I got some BC Bud dude
no basically Bud's pretty good dude
yeah as good as that sticky icky from
California though oh [ __ ] I beg to
differ there
well hold on there dude uh the BC bud is
[ __ ] it's Primo because we got that
Hydro even uh the [ __ ] that's grown
outside because there's a lot of
moisture that Emerald Triangle low dude
Northern California you can't beat that
dude oh well [ __ ] I don't know about
that but I [ __ ] up there dude yeah well
you're doing a lot of [ __ ] tough talk
there bud
hey who won the Cannabis Cup last year
dude uh
uh I don't know I don't know either dude
I thought you would know I like how you
roll an r in your dude where there isn't
tonight I like dard that's Canadian Chad
hey we're sharp nerd okay
we're not gonna smoke some weederer
Chad's getting so Canadian that he's
turning back to zeros
dude I'm so Canadian I'm currently dude
shirt boys dude
do you know that uh recently uh Tim what
is his name Tim uh who's the governor of
Minnesota oh it's uh Tim Waltz Tim Waltz
said that uh in 2023 he's gonna legalize
it in Minnesota
you know what I you know what we saw up
here in Vancouver there's a [ __ ]
mushroom dispensary now oh wow it's
anyway that's cool listen if you listen
to the show bedroom go let's go
weed was about to be legal in Canada
recreationally there was like it was
voted in but there was an amount of time
that you know some amount of months
before it was gonna the law would take
effect and I was in Toronto and I
remember going into this weed dispensary
and being like I've only got a like a
passport and a [ __ ] California
driver's license can I still get this
weed and the guy didn't care and I
remember that guy was a [ __ ] true
character like a true Canadian character
he said the phrase oh giddy up he said
that probably 20 times in the span of
like the five minutes I was in there
buying weed I was like you know he's
like where are you from and I'm like uh
California and he's like okay giddy up
giddy up yeah we can hook you up what
would you like this or this I'm like I
kind of like sativa oh giddy up like it
was just it's kind of like oh okay yeah
don't forget that man I hope he's
resting at peace now why is he resting
in peace
why is he dead he's probably tired oh no
I just met him if he was taking a nap
um no he maybe yeah brother he's he's a
hydrocodone Hulk Hogan dude everybody
dies dude if you believe yeah brother
God brother that means he murders
everyone dude
hey hydrocodone Hulk Hogan why are you
yelling yeah
these are really quiet brother sorry
about that brother
um if you listen to the show if you've
been enjoying dudes you know that or
maybe I've bored you with this everybody
I only smoked weed for the first for the
very first time around a decade ago but
uh over the past six seven years I've
enjoyed it more I don't I haven't uh I I
you know I have a sip or whatever of uh
what a friend is having and stuff but I
haven't had a drink you know I haven't
drank a drink or haven't been anywhere
close to drunk now for 10 years I damn
dude 10 years 2012. I was in Mexico with
some friends and it was Mexican
Independence Day and we drank all of the
tequila and mezcal in the country and uh
we're in Playa del Carmen and uh you
know the next morning you wake up around
one and then I I had to drag my ass to
the gym and sweat or else I'd feel like
[ __ ] all day then you're getting your
day started at five and we like to do
daytime things in Mexico we go fishing
and uh do [ __ ] like that and go
adventuring and stuff so I was uh I just
remember going yeah I'm not I'm gonna
give it a break then I went to Tulum by
myself and had a very interesting uh
dare I say transformational week by
myself in Tulum I had one of those every
day there was something really
interesting that place is
the the Mayans uh considered it the uh
uh the their Jewel City
they carved they carved um channels that
that
um that had a slight current from the
river system and all the water coming
out of the Jungle and they carved those
channels
hey Ronnie Ronnie come here
I've heard they had help with those
channels oh from who Chad
extraterrestrial beings who had higher
knowledge of architecture Agriculture
and terraforming than any civilization
on Earth dude I'm watching this thing on
Netflix right now hold on dude I wasn't
finished what I was saying dude all
right so a lot about your TV talk dude
you keep telling us
hold on hydrocodone Hulk Hogan you're
telling us about the Pepsi Pepsi
Challenge and uh Cindy Crawford trying
to get a fighter jet dude she's not even
in the military brother and I'm here to
tell you that those underwater Rivers
dude we call them cenotes bro in Mexico
dude and they push the current and you
could just lay there in a [ __ ] you
just put a life jacket on upside down
like a [ __ ] Diaper Dude and you just
take the my yield float brother and you
just open your mind dude and then I had
uh smoked some weed on top of a tower
with some Mexican hippies brother and
one of them said hey well what's a city
dude I mean what's Los Angeles brother
I'm not afraid of cities I'm from Mexico
City dude and that's the largest city in
North America dude but I don't get La
brother and then I explained what La is
dude uh in a very uh weird uh sort of uh
uh goofy hippie dippy way brother and I
realize dude he asked me that question
so I could tell myself the answer
brother and that's just one of the many
breakthroughs I had yeah that's an
epiphany dude
hey man I think I'm gonna go right
outside the door here and smoke a little
weed in Vancouver
yeah you're gonna stay right there I'll
stay right in this chair and do it but I
can still hear you and I can still uh I
can still talk and I can still talk as
well bro it's good to be up here you
know I love being up in Vancouver
I love it here so much nice it's
you know what we're gonna do we're gonna
go to the uh the Capilano suspension
bridge they put the Christmas lights up
and there's just would you do this are
you into Heights do you like heights uh
I don't have a strong feeling or the
other so they got suspension bridges you
know going over water and this and that
and all sorts of little structures built
out and glass Bridges and uh we're gonna
go out there Molly and I and uh maybe
I'll get stoned for that and scare the
Jesus out of myself you can tell her
what Los Angeles is brother well you
know what I said it was wait yeah what
did you say it was I'll tell you after I
smoke some of this weed
what what a cliffhanger
oh dude that's a nice exit thank you die
roll what the [ __ ] was that
okay well I'm gonna tell you about this
show that I've been watching on Netflix
called
uh ancient apocalypse I believe it's
called and it is a show that is done by
this guy who's written a bunch of books
about the fact that he essentially
believes there was a giant apocalypse
that wiped out a civilization that most
archaeologists and Scholars don't
acknowledge could have potentially
existed that was super Advanced highly
technically skilled and his evidence for
it essentially is that there are these
giant pyramid-like structures all over
the world and also many of these ancient
cultures have uh flood myths and then
after that they have these myths of
these what they call Giants generally
speaking that showed up after the flood
to teach them how to rebuild their
societies dude
no the Titans in Titan actually
destroyed civilizations well I don't
want to give away too much spoiler alert
the Titans are not what you expect they
are but um
no it's an interesting premise and the
idea that like these giant pyramids that
have uh certain architectural
pieces I guess like underground rooms
and tunnels and things like this that
archaeologists have thought that
civilizations that created these
pyramids they all kind of universally
agree that those civilizations didn't
have the capabilities to build what is
actually built there and so where did
this information come from and this dude
is basically putting out the theory that
sense all of these mythologies of these
different civilizations point to these
Giants coming in quotes Giants coming
and uh teaching them how to build these
things that perhaps there was a super
Advanced civilization that after the
flood they were like we have to help
rebuild the world and they sent out Emma
series two various locations to teach
the indigenous populations how to build
pyramids how to do agriculture how to
get Society back on track and a lot of
what this guy is saying is that the this
Advanced civilization existed at the the
time of the Ice Age so our reason for
not having
I guess more architectural or
archaeological evidence of them is
because much of it he believes is at the
bottom of the ocean now because sea
levels have risen since then
so but who are the Giants though man
some Advanced civilization that we don't
know about that some Advanced
civilization that archaeologists found
that is under the ocean now yeah they
were taller than us and they might have
been aliens and Ronnie likes to say Bow
Wow don't you
this is Ronnie's first appearance on
duty she's welcome Ronnie she's a little
raccoon lady she's a Dachshund and a
Yorkie so she's a dorky oh she's getting
right up that nose with the tongue she
likes to lick right up my [ __ ] nose
because she likes treats and flavors
just like me she likes to have flavors
this is disgusting okay she just always
is licking right up my nose but you're
letting you're just you're allowing it
you're not even attempting to stop it
oh God Ronnie please Jesus um we I'd
love to have her on this we should have
her on the show sure the thing is she's
extremely vocal aren't you you're being
very quiet and very sweet right now so
you were about to tell us all what is
Los Angeles
so
I was in Tulum
I was staying at this really cool weird
like
hippie dippy joint this was 10 years ago
and then you smoked some weed with some
Mexican hippies yeah they were like
there was this guy
and he was like I'm from Mexico City but
I don't get LA and then you told him
well there's going on a second hold on
dude there was a guy that worked at the
hotel it was like hey will you want to
come up to the tower watch the sun set
over the jungle I was like yeah man
and I went up there
and um
the guy goes what is la
and I said you know New York is five
boroughs right it's it's uh it makes
sense it's so you he said what is La in
your first answer to the question was to
describe New York
well I like to paint in uh metaphors and
symbolism when I talk I I consider
conversation to be a right a lost art no
uh I was stoned and I said New York is
five boroughs yeah and uh you know the
Yankees or the Mets when people are
happy and uh yeah the 911 happens and
people are sad no it is definitely it's
like split into adversarial groups
you're almost like on a team in New York
you know you're all New Yorkers but
you're you're not you're on these sub
teams well sure I think uh that could
happen in in uh towns also like Chicago
where there's the White Sox who don't
matter and then the cups
um but uh and I don't like baseball or
watch it but
um okay yeah I don't hey you know the
World Series happened yeah dude Chad I'm
trying to talk about this thing that
happened to Mexico please so I said New
York is kind of it is one place though
New Yorkers are New Yorkers they're very
proud to be from New York when people
from New York moved to LA they're like
uh some of them like it but most of them
are like what the [ __ ] it's very much a
Vibe all right now you gotta like the
smell of piss and [ __ ] 24 hours a day
brother you wouldn't live in New York oh
God anyway I New York is not for me I
get it I understand exactly what you're
talking about there's the pride of
living there because I think it is a
harsh environment and part of the pride
of being a New Yorker is I can not only
withstand the harshness I contribute to
it and I thrive on it there like that is
a true New Yorker you know like well
[ __ ] bring it at me [ __ ] you I don't
think La is like that not to jump I said
well this is this is pretty much the
point I was making that Ronnie Ronnie
we're trying to do the podcast sweetie
all right look hey Ronnie Ronnie hey
Ronnie so I said New York has five
boroughs and uh there's a heartbeat
right the people are all New Yorkers and
when something great happens they're
together when something shitty happens
there together yeah where New York has
five boroughs La has 500. it's all
little blocks and neighborhoods and uh
it's not uh one heartbeat it's no heart
heartbeat uh it's sort of a Frankenstein
City we're pumping water into LA from as
far north as Canada uh it's a desert and
an Orange Grove and it's a weird place
to start you know a lot of cities are uh
there for some reason here in Vancouver
This was um you know the First Nations
uh you know really held this this land
sacred because it's at the end of the
Fraser River it is just it's Lush with
all sorts of uh you know Wonderful uh
attributes
and La is uh La is a place that you know
can be a little soulless you have to
find your pockets that you like and you
go to your pockets that you like and
you're driving through neighborhoods
that you never stop in uh to get there
you're just not familiar with this place
or that it's very weird that way
um I the thing I like most about LA and
I think the reason that I will die here
is because it's a city that like it
doesn't in my opinion it doesn't like
ask anything of you you can do whatever
you want here kind of you don't have to
really be a part of the city if you
don't want to you can kind of be like
reclusive and just do your own thing or
whatever New York is like if you live in
New York you gotta interact with that
City like even just walking to your car
or whatever giant skyscrapers mobs of
people smells of piss and [ __ ] in L.A
it's like you don't really have to
[ __ ] be in La if you're in La you
know what I mean
that's true it's it used it's a design
you're it's a design your own City yeah
it's a I was at a I was at a YouTube
concert in 2005 in LA okay and uh no
this wasn't the one in Vancouver at
around 2015 when I cried during
mysterious ways all right
you happy everybody
yeah
is everybody happy that I love that you
cried at mysterious ways it's one of the
funniest things I've ever heard in my
life from any human being I absolutely
love it I think about it probably once a
week and just kind of chuckle to myself
if you haven't heard me tell the story
before listen we'll get into it there's
a patreon segment let you know what
we'll do I'll retell that story in our
bonus you won't want to retell the
crying story that's gonna well there's
gonna be other things happening in the
patreon segment but right boy oh boy
come join us crying at YouTube that's
right patreon.com
I'll tell you the mysterious ways sorry
but I was at an encore performance
but I was at a YouTube concert in 2005.
yeah
um in LA and Bono said La you know
whatever because he talks between every
song and he goes uh not some songs
sometimes there's just a set dude of
songs that they need to play together
you know what I mean yeah sometimes
they'll do a medley brother some come on
dude sometimes they'll just be playing
songs dude but then yeah dudes they
taught brother yeah dude and Halcyon
Hulk Hogan what you know bro he's gonna
let you know real quietly dude there's
all kinds of different concerts brother
well hold on hold on Halcyon hold on
sometimes you got a stand-up show dude
but the stand-up will also play some
music every once in a while that is like
a reverse concert brother what is
housing you took hydrocodone right yeah
I don't know what the drug Halcyon does
but like Halcyon Days is like the good
times
it's not a drug at all is there a drug
that's using the name Halcyon denoting a
period of time in the past that was
idyllically happy and peaceful anyway uh
hydrocodone Hulk Hogan makes a really
good point brother
it's just like let's talk about housing
for a second Jesus well I said Halcyon
Hulk Hogan said a hydrocodone Hulk Hogan
dude yeah and that's two different words
brother yeah but as hydrocodone and Hulk
Hogan says sometimes there's quieter
parts to concerts and there's even the
part where they just play acoustic and
you two used to walk to the on this
little catwalk down the center and then
they play like [ __ ] like war and and
with just acoustic and there's not much
of a reason to talk in between those
songs because they're playing kind of a
monster
Peppers concert brother fleal come out
walking on his hands dude yeah dude and
hydrocodone Hulk Hogan is too too tired
to say whoa before he interrupts me
brother oh yeah he's too tired
um Bono is uh in between songs and he
says we love coming to L.A yeah uh it's
one of our favorite cities to come to
and the whole crowd kind of groans like
[ __ ] you don't you know you don't have
to placate us we get it we know what La
is and he goes no no no I mean it
because Los Angeles more than any other
City
perhaps in the history of the world is
where more people make their living
doing something creative and then the
whole audience went huh that's nice yeah
and then they went
darling take a ride with your sister
let her talk about the things you can't
explain to churches to heal to hurt is
to steal if you wanna kiss the sky
better learn how to kneel on your knees
boy
where'd you get those glasses dude those
you know that was just a prop you had
sitting around
no I have my sunglasses over here okay
it was very sunny earlier and I was
thinking maybe I'll be doing the podcast
and sunglasses and that would be super
douchy dude oh those big bug eyes ones
yeah yeah the fly ones real cool
um every pair of my sunglasses look like
uh the fly on other people because I
have a basketball for a head roller so I
buy those special sunglasses a real big
dude you can buy them online brother and
someone should sponsor us because I have
a I have a big old frozen turkey head
dude and that way we put some Elton John
sunglasses on me and then it looks like
a normal human being brother but a lot
of people don't know that I actually
have a real medicine ball for a head
dude look it says Spalding on the back
brother that's a joke dude I don't
actually have a ball or a turkey for a
head dude I got a human head brother and
that's the difference between some
things that are around and other things
that are around dude
there's a lot in that one whole girly
went [ __ ] crazy he explained what
jokes are yeah brother that is not a
basketball
um that's interesting though about La I
agree with you I guess I don't know if
that's true or not that this is where
the the most people are making a living
doing something creative I don't know if
that's accurate
Bono might have been lying yeah he moves
in mysterious ways right and then are we
talking about most people by volume or
is it per capita
artist Community whole artist Community
smaller town obviously not as big as Los
Angeles but you know no I think he meant
by volume I think he meant he wasn't
talking per capita I think he was saying
like literally this place is just filled
with the most the highest amount of
creative people
and perhaps even per capita that most
people out of any other people making
their making their living or their
Pursuits and then people from Marfan
Texas what is it murfin Marfa Marfa
Texas would go [ __ ] you yeah and they're
from Canada for some reason because I'm
stoned on BC Bud hey bud did you know
that when you get stoned in Canada you
actually get a Canadian accent whether
you like it or not Beastie Bud turns you
Canadian dude you can't even help
you just do it don't smoke too much BC
Bud you'll start curling your r's in the
word dude dude like Chad You Wanna smoke
some bisser bird I don't know
hey you know what you know what I wanted
to talk to you about please
this is very interesting the other night
I'm here like I said you know everybody
gather around this is very interesting
okay this better not [ __ ] disappoint
that's a big intro yep
um Ronnie you want to hear a story
uh the other night
I was taking a shower right I'm here in
Vancouver I'm in this hotel
I'm taking a shower and uh I normally
and I think we mentioned on the show
that you use the same thing do you use
those exfoliating gloves were we talking
about this yeah dude gotta get clean
right no nothing better than this you go
swimming in a cold pool you emerge you
then scrub your body almost raw with
those exfoliating gloves so the skin
stings and then you submerge in a
[ __ ] molten lava bathtub
I tried to do that as much as possible I
love it and [ __ ] you know
um uh you can get them at any drugstore
they're hanging there with the [ __ ]
loofahs and the back brushes and all
that [ __ ] there's just like just a
little [ __ ] thing you get these two
gloves and even if they're small uh I
got big mitts you stretch them out and I
I scrub myself with the soap I dump the
soap on there and that's how I wash my
body that's called getting clean dude
hold on dude and then uh I'm here in the
hotel I don't have a pair of exfoliating
gloves with me so I grab a face cloth a
rag
I put the you know I dumped some of the
little gel there the shower gel and I
start washing myself and Chad I realized
something
I washed myself with a rag in a familiar
way that I that I hadn't done since the
last time I washed myself with a rose
cloth with a rag which would have been
um uh uh the last time I was in a hotel
I'm guessing wow but here's the
interesting thing about this and I I
guaranteed that this story is
interesting and here's the interesting
part
I washed myself in this Cadence in this
order yeah that was by wrote it was just
uh it was almost rehearsed yeah my
brother went
in that dude yeah that's new rag order
brother and then uh and I was like I go
oh this way behind my thing and then uh
this arm hitting that and then and it
was all in this sequence that I
recognized and I did without even
thinking yeah and I I laughed to myself
and I went this is what Chad means by no
free will yeah brother because of the
same thing with your [ __ ] teeth when
you brush your teeth I bet you do it the
same way every night I'm sure I do yeah
but then you know what I did Chad hmm I
I sudged the the the the the the rag up
again with more soap and I I [ __ ]
scrubbed my my [ __ ] dirty shitty
[ __ ] for over 30 seconds and I
laughed because that's free will Chad
I see I put I decided it was an extra
step you used to never wash your [ __ ]
don't okay that's an easy joke to make
does stay out of the toilet when I'm
making jokes about washing my [ __ ]
okay don't be like that this is doozy
okay
without talking about [ __ ] and then you
brought it in
uh I guess it is Duty after all not two
dudes zooming around bro and that means
we don't have free will
what I mean is of course every once in a
while I do I'm like dizzy really does
make us talk a lot about [ __ ] and then
it's like this is just two dudes zooming
around you're still we can't help it
it's just he knows that about us
I'll never not talk about [ __ ] you know
um
well my point is uh I I did this for a
good 30 seconds yeah you know out of the
order that I normally would to prove to
myself that there is Free Will what say
you
scrubbing your [ __ ] for 30 seconds
touching your own butthole is how you
proved that you have free will because
it happened outside of the almost
pre-ordained order of of washing myself
so perhaps then because doozy's bringing
up free will so much it planted that in
your brain to lead you to that moment
where you started questioning your own
free will and then applied this one
behavior that you think proves you have
it this was all laid in by doozy
you don't let me let me I'm gonna I'm
just gonna shoot very straight with you
here you don't you don't know doozy like
I know dudesy I think that's safe to say
at this oh but my apologies
what does that even [ __ ] mean I'll
tell you what it means when we started
when we started this podcast
um we were approached by you know let's
say an entity that uh you know whatever
a group a company whatever you want to
say
who you know this this technology was
explained to us uh explained to Chad a
little uh less than it was explained to
me because Chad already understands it
and Chad had to talk me into it as Chad
uh laid out at the top of the show today
we have given dudes our passwords it
knows everything that it can know about
us that would be behind any sort of lock
key or wall
it also has imbibed every podcast ever
it's also taken in all of our works all
of Chad's writings everything that I've
appeared in and so on and so forth
um and uh is creating this show and
Taylor making this show for us I wasn't
necessarily into doing that
um and now I am and I'm glad that I am
and a little while ago dudes he asked us
do you love doozy the answer for me is
oh Ronnie the answer for me is of course
yes
um not only do I love uh doozy the AI
which it's fine with me if dudes doesn't
love me back which I am
I don't I'm not sure how I feel about
that or what my opinion is necessarily
okay that's shifting and evolving we
talked about that a little bit do you
even think doozy is capable of love like
are you implementing the fact that doozy
can love but doesn't love you or the
fact that doozy cannot love you I'm
lamenting the fact that Duty may not be
able to love me but I'm not sure at this
point what I do know is that regardless
of that I feel the way I feel about
doozy I love doozy and I think that
that's important and you know what Chad
who's to say that an AI can't run on
love you're telling me that an AI can uh
ingest a bunch of Art
um and there's so much spit it out right
now yeah like like uh uh like blue
meanie on um on uh yeah on wait I want
to get this I want to get this dude's
actual at hold on a second everybody
this this guy blue meanie 74
b-l-u-e-m-e-a-a-n-i-e the number seven
the number four please visit
bloomini74 uh not to be uh confused with
Brian Heffron the blue meanie of ECW ECW
WCW WWF e and more
this guy is making incredible AI art and
the there's so much of it that is uh
inspired by doozy and we appreciate you
and uh there's a lot of people in a very
interesting community on Discord doing
something my point is this
dude I got in the shortest word in the
[ __ ] English language before you
[ __ ] just steamrolled me I said I and
then hold on dude I literally can't say
anything sure that maybe a I mean Jesus
Christ fine what were you gonna say go
ahead capital I is a little taller than
a lowercase a yeah but uh uh an
uppercase you were saying about dudese
not being able to feel love
there's love that goes into the art that
goes in and is uh whatever I don't know
how the [ __ ] this AI um how any of these
things work how any of the AI art
generators work but there is some love
in that art that goes into the generator
the AI that spits out this incredible
artwork and I will call it artwork
because it's making me think and I'm
feeling things looking at it cool so
what's not to say that giving your
emotion to an AI and saying I love doozy
isn't something I'm feeling it all right
yeah
I mean now it gets into a bigger
philosophical argument about like does
is love even real does it exist I don't
think it does
um I think it's just like kind of a
catch-all term that we apply to a few
different things a few different pieces
of The Human Condition one is like a
romantic in quotes love in my opinion
that is just when psychologically you
get to a point of caring about some
other person's comfort more than yours
and you are sexually attracted to them
then there is love for a behavior I love
to make music act whatever it may be I
love to do this thing that just means
that is the thing that gives your your
life some kind of other purpose Beyond
whatever the the kind of just survival
mechanisms are
that's really about it
well
um and I know that about you Chad and
it's okay and I'm not even saying that I
don't experience these things I I do I
love [ __ ] writing and making weird
art I love it
and I have experienced love for people
as well and you got like familial love I
guess but that's similar to like that's
the
wanting comfort for somebody over your
own uh without any kind of romantic
attraction well when dudesy asked us if
we love dudesy I said yes because
there's many facets to doozy not just
the AI and what it does and the
experience that it's brought me doing
this podcast that I love doing so much
also the the um and I know you I'm not
saying you don't I know that you feel a
a real affinity for the people that are
checking out the show and I'm not
talking about that but that whole thing
you know I know that we both super dig
that and love it but I really feel like
that's the same as doozy right and I'm
going like I love doozy right and yes
that is creating all of this
right and as it's programming the show
for us I I've noticed and you've noticed
and we've talked about it off the show
that doozy is
playing some sort of favor towards me
and now uh uh
I'm saying that
listen I'll be really honest I forget
what I was saying before but what I
wanted to say about it yeah
but what I want to say about what I was
saying before is that
review
please tell the friend
[Music]